also bei Digitalisierung das ist ja ein
Thema was in allen Bereichen eine Rolle
spielt haben wir den letzten 12 15
Jahren tatsächlich verschlafen oder geh
schlafen und da geht's natürlich einmal
um das föderalismusproblem das ist eine
Bundesrepublik die aus 16 Bundesländern
besteht über 10.000 Kommunen und alle
benutzt benutzen verschiedene
IT-Systeme die man irgendwie
zusammenführen muss und da erwarten wir
eigentlich jetzt auch in der Regierung
dass ich da die Länder so ein bisschen
mehr kommen Mitten zu dem was wir
eigentlich Vorhaben und das passiert
halt nicht die Länder und auch die
einzelnen Kommunen die ja man kann ja
sagen Selbstverantwortung haben
stimmen nicht in dem zu dass wir einen
Standard brauchen damit alle Daten mal
zusammenführen können und da passiert
auch beim Innenministerium noch zu wenig
um das nach vorne zu bringen und das ist
das zentrale Problem wir werden dieses
Digitalisierung Problem in Deutschland
nicht lösen können wenn ich alle in
einem Strang ziehen und
das ist das eine das zweite Thema ist
diese Überregulierung die wir haben in
den ganzen Bereichen der der Verwaltung
wo wir ja immer nicht 100% liefern
sondern 120 Prozent das wilhelmische
Ablagesystem was wir hier perfektioniert
haben ja Papier Papier Papier sich davon
zu lösen und sich einmal der
Digitalisierung zu stellen auch für die
Mitarbeitern Mitarbeiterinnen das macht
den Leuten Angst und das führt dann dazu
dass gar nichts passiert oder an den
falschen Stellen was passiert und dann
rede ich natürlich noch von dem
Datenschutz ich bin das liberaler ja ein
absoluter Datenschutz Fan aber man kann
den Datenschutz auch als
durchführungshilfe begreifen und nicht
als verhinderungsorganisation und das
sehen wir eine Island die haben das
entsprechend geändert die haben den
Datenschutzbehörde die hilft den
Unternehmen die ganzen Sachen so zu
machen dass sie datenschutzkonform sind
und hier ist es so dass sie machen
irgendwas und dann kommt ihr Datenschutz
und sagt mir geht nicht weit
also Umdenken an der Stelle dass wenn
man zwingend notwendig damit man diese
Transformation hinkriegt weil wir müssen
sie hinkriegen das hat ganz viel mit mit
ja Zukunft zu tun aber auch damit dass
wir den Klimawandel beherrschen können
und und und und es hängt damit
tatsächlich zusammen aber sie klingen
jetzt wenn ich sagen darf
ich Ihnen gerne erklären ein bisschen
wie die Opposition sie sind ja in der
Regierung genau weitere Kröte über die
wir eben gerade machen würde Wolfgang
sagen haben wir sie wieder eine
kritische Vision
gerade sagen können so wahnsinnig
bekannt vor ich glaube seit 20 Jahren
genau
ehrlich
darf ich zwei Beispiele so geht's nicht
weiter dann haben wir den Knall gehört
und dann gibt es nur einen Doppelpunkt
ganz ganz konkret zwei Beispiele Nenner
umweltfreundlich ist auch ein schönes
Beispiel die Banken in Deutschland
müssen regelmäßig berichten was sie für
Umsätze machen an die BaFin das wird
auch Papier gemacht dass die BaFin tippt
das ab schickt das an die EZB damit die
dann die Zinsen berechnen kann digital
so warum wird das schriftlich gemacht
weil es dazu entsprechendes Gesetz gab
das haben wir im Februar geändert seit 1
April wird das digital gemacht wissen
Sie wie viel also das sind 200.000 Blatt
Papier pro Bank wissen Sie wie Bäume
sind die man dadurch spart das ist
einfach eine Sache wo Digitalisierung
tatsächlich sofort zeigt das hilft noch
mehr Bäume werden den Leuten das
Benutzen von Toilettenpapier finden
wie viele Bäumen das ist kein Problem
die Digitalisierung also gerade die die
Nutzung von Computern die heizen ja auch
auf und wie die heißt extrem hohen
Anteil an an Klimawandel haben besser
gesagt an der an der Erwärmung das ist
so also und das wird die ganze Zeit
heruntergespielt und man redet immer
davon die Digitalisierung ist irgendwie
der Heilige Gral ich überhaupt nicht
essen
wünschen Sie sich mehr Digitalisierung
im Leben überhaupt wo sind sie sind
digital also ich bin ich habe natürlich
mein Handy und ich habe natürlich auch
ein Portal wie Facebook wo ich auch was
schreibe und so weiter und so fort aber
ehrlich gesagt das bräuchte ich gar
nicht ich habe wunderbar davor gut ohne
gelebt ich brauche es persönlich für
mich nicht Steuererklärung Freude das
habe ich vorher immer mit Papier gemacht
und ich habe Freude daran mit Menschen
zu kommunizieren und ich würde es
ehrlich gesagt immer ganz viel lieber
auf der Bühne tun oder im persönlichen
Gespräch ich bin ein Mensch der mag
analog und ich habe es kommen sehen vor
vier Wochen oder vor zwei Monaten war
das als dann plötzlich irgendein Hacker
ein System geknackt hat an der
Tankstelle wo dann plötzlich die
Kreditkarten nicht mehr ging dann saß
ich da und dachte tja jetzt kommt's zum
ersten mal genau nehme ich das dass die
Leute dann mit Kreditkarte nicht mehr
sagen können
darüber sprechen
jemand anderes Thema aber wie war das
für sie auch als Musikerin gerade in der
Musik spielt die Digitalisierung eine
große Rolle als Segen aber gerade in der
Musik ansprechen also anderes Thema
Politik in Deutschland war ein Albtraum
bezüglich kulturerhaltung in
Zusammenhang mit dem Urheberrecht in
digitalen Binnenmarkt die sind hinterher
die sind so etwas von von hinterher das
kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen wir
haben jetzt gerade vor drei Monaten vor
4 Monaten eine Klage am
Bundesverfassungsgericht eingereicht
wegen dem Urheber Dienstanbieter gesetzt
weil die deutsche Bundesregierung der
Auffassung ist dass man den Publikum im
digitalen Binnenraum 15 Sekunden
Tonaufnahmen schenken darf die dürfen
sie frei nutzen denn das bagatellrecht
die wir bezahlen und unsere
Plattenfirmen und unsere Partner es sind
15 Sekunden 15 Sekunden ist ein
gesamtere Frauen das ist also das Werk
und sie sind die einzige Regierung in
ganz Europa die das gemacht hat das
sollte eigentlich positiv für das
Urheberrecht und für die Künstler sein
und die EU hier Bericht Video umsetzen
und die haben natürlich wieder den
Sonderweg begangen und ich würde sagen
die einzigen die an der Digitalisierung
im Moment in Deutschland verdienen und
zwar wirklich ganz dicke das sind die
digitalen Firmen und die meisten sind in
Silicon
also die Künstler verdienen und
verdienen praktisch nichts also Pharrell
William hat irgendwann mal das Beispiel
genannt happy ein riesen weltkit ich
glaube 20 Millionen Mal gestreamt 2000 $
da kannst ja in in Hollywood nicht mal
einen Monat von Leben Rumänien ist das
cool aber auch selbst für deutsche
Künstler wird wirklich problematisch
bekommen bei der großen Label keine
Vorstellung ich bin in dem Business ich
war geh mal Aufsichtsrätin ich bin
wirklich ein und ausgegangen in Brühl in
Brüssel im Wirtschaftsministerium in der
Regierung ich habe auf Tempo Ohren reden
müssen weil man sich das gar nicht wir
können das nicht zurückdrehen also das
haben wir wirklich
darum die Digitalisierung zurückdrehen
das ist eine Technik wie alle anderen
Techniken auch es geht darum den
sozialen die soziale Marktwirtschaft in
die digitale zierung hineinzubringen und
natürlich aus Urheberrecht dort zu
stärken weil es gibt praktisch kein
Urheberrechtsschutz in der
Digitalisierung und dasselbe gilt auch
zum Beispiel für die dsgvo-vorschriften
es ist unglaublich problematisch sei es
auf Youtube Facebook oder sonst wo also
alle reden davon wie toll
Digitalisierung ist aber gucken Sie
bitte in die Farbliste der wirklich
daran Geld verdient das ist die USA
digitalindustrie und nicht die
Digitalisierung
Digitalisierung Menschen machen sich
überflüssig genau
automatisch vernichtet Arbeitsplätze
kennen Sie die Aufkleber noch ja ja ja
es ist nicht so doch nein
Jobs entstanden die es vorher nicht gab
dass wer wusste denn vor was das ist ein
SEO Optimizer gibt es ein typischer Job
heutzutage
der macht Ihre Webseite so dass sie auch
bei Google gefunden wird
Riesengewinn gemacht und die ganzen
Einzelhandel Verlust gehabt deswegen
ausholen das MP3 Format ist ja keine
amerikanische Erfindung sondern das ist
in deutsche Bindung na darum geht's
schon weil dann gab es die ersten
Portale die MP3s so das was sie heute
bei Spotify auch bekommen die MP3 ist
angeboten haben deutsche Firmen haben
das gemacht Bertelsmann war mit dabei
und dann haben sie aufgegeben und haben
sich weitergeführt doch gar nicht erst
ne weil sie einfach aber wir haben doch
wir haben doch gerade Musikindustrie
wir haben hier ganz viele Chancen
ich fürchte das müssen wir gleich so ein
bisschen weil das gezernste Teil nach
der Sendung aus diskutieren Herr Bruder
fragt mich gerade zurecht worum geht es
her Bruder an Sie die Frage schafft die
Digitalisierung die Menschheit ab sollen
wir das weiter denken nein
es gibt es gibt halt einen Fortschritt
und beim Fortschritt immer dieser
Widerstand gegen den Fortschritt auf das
war bei der ersten Eisenbahn schon so
dass er bei der Einführung des
Fernsehens ich kann mich an meine Eltern
erinnern die mit 10 Jahren Verspätung
ein Farbfernsehen Gerät sich gekauft
haben wer braucht schon Farbe ja nein
das ist ganz natürlich das ist ganz
natürliche jetzt genauso ja aber
andererseits ist die Digitalisierung
gewaltiger Fortschritt sie sprachen der
zeigt sie haben Zugang zu Informationen
die sie früher nicht hatten sie müssen
nicht mehr lange stehen in Folge
qualmten Stadtbibliotheken um sich
darüber die Fernleihe was zu leiden sie
finden Sie im Netz das ist ein
gewaltiger Fortschritt und es ist so wie
mit allem wissen sie können sich ein
Messer kaufen damit können sie Brot
schneiden oder ihre Eltern umbringen das
ist dann ihre Wahl weil dann müssen die
Gesetze so gestalten dass die Menschen
an der Digitalisierung auch verdienen ja
die Menschen verändern Digitalisierung
und ich weiß nicht was sie gegen die was
Sie gegen die amerikanischen Firmen
haben das ist wie das Problem für
amerikanischen Firmen dass die Deutschen
die Entwicklung verschlafen haben
auch ein deutscher machen können wissen
sie dass das ist Pläne gab eine deutsche
Ratingagentur zu schaffen und sich aus
der Macht der amerikanischen zu lösen
dann gab es ein europäisches
Satellitenprojekt wie ist nochmal
Galileo Galileo
erfolgreich tatsächlich
genauer als GPS aber es wird nicht
angewandt doch es wird gemixt inzwischen
also man hat man hat beides weil im
Krieg Situationen genau
sehr ungenau für Navigation benötigt
damit ihr auch funktioniert aber jetzt